I'll be going over my
solution in a second.
But, if you want to inspect it for
yourself, you can find a link to
it in the downloadable section.
First things first,
I want my images to fit.
I set the max width on
the image tag to 100%.
And look at that.
Now the images are actually
fitting inside the view port.
You can see the whole thing instead of
some massive, stretched out monster.
Then I set the width on
the article tag to 50m.
You can immediately see that
the content is actually fitting.
The blog's starting to look
a lot more reasonable but
the browser is still downloading
images that are way too large.
I need some smaller images.
I could use a tool like
OS10 Preview to resize and
compress each image individually,
but that really isn't scalable.
So, I used this grunt task to create new
images that were scaled and compressed.
I set a width of 1600 pixels for
2x displays.
At a width of 50 m on a 1x display an
image is going to be 800 pixels across.
But, on a 2x display,
it's going to be 1600 pixels so,
I went with the large one.
I thought 30% still looked good while
keeping the bites to a minimum.
Additionally I'm appending large_2x
to the end of each file for
reasons that will make
sense later in the course.
With all that done all I have to
do is change the image sources to
images/whatever-600_large_2x and bam.
My page just got a lot smaller.
Check it out.
After the changes,
my page is down to 1.3 megabytes,
which I'm feeling really good about.
And lastly, I used the figure tag,
because it includes
the awesome figcaption tag.
Simply fill in the caption in
figcaption, and it shows up on the page.
So the blog is looking a lot better
overall, but it's still not perfect.
At the end of the next lesson, you'll
have another chance to improve the blog.